let me explain what we're doing we did
differentiating an exponential that had
some other ways a like 2 or 3 or PI or
whatever right that's just Exponential's
that's just one half of the picture
what about logs here's a log with an on
eBay so another base right so how do I
change as well as I've seen before if I
can rewrite this in a form that's easier
to work with so there does have an e
base then I'm good to go right
thankfully I have the Lord that's all
about changing the basis of logs right
what's it called change a base law very
original right so I've got my fraction I
want things in base II remember
so I'm going to choose base E as my new
log is that okay where did the rest the
numbers go yeah I I like to think these
guys once higher ones lower they end up
preserving into the same positions here
so there goes the X there goes the two
right there okay now what I'm gonna then
say is two things number one I'm lazy so
rather than writing in his log base E
I'm just gonna write Ln there's no L in
there there's my two adjustments but
hold on a second see the log two on the
bottom log two on the bottom it's just a
number like you can go your calculator
you can find out what log 2 is I'm not
really interested in where this is zero
point seven or so like that yeah okay so
if this is just a number then I can
stick it out the front of all the stuff
with the X do you agree with that it's
just a number at the front it's a
gross-looking number but it's just a
number if it's just a number I can now
differentiate this really easily this is
y right I have a differentiator yet and
under calculus now I'm going to write
here we go let's differentiate this
number at the front it's just going to
stay at the front what's the derivative
of log base a of X this is just one one
of the nice really easy results right 1
over X so therefore if I just want to
simplify this it's 1 over X log 2
so what I can do here is I can say well
what if it wasn't - what if it was any
number that you like
right well I'll change this into log
base a and any number that you'd like
and what you end up with is a derivative
one over there's that X from the 1 over
X there and it's log of whatever that
base was okay
in our case it was - all right that make
sense so this result here
differentiating Logs with any base is
really straightforward once you know how
to deal with that